[Musique]
ça c'est tu cherch non non c'est
bon oui
je je fais pas confiance mais je suis
obligé d'acheter de l'eau puis que on
nous dit que l'eau a du clorcn l'eau a
du plomb l'eau a des comment on dit en
crayau de caca alors moi je je ne sais
pas on est on est quand même un certain
âge mais même les jeunes quand j'ai mes
petits enfants qui viennent c'est de
l'eau je suis obligé j'achète des
bouteilles comme il y en a pas parce que
je veux pas qu'il boiv cette
eau
une
poussièreelle beaucoup de gens souffrent
parce qu'il y en a qui peuvent pas
acheter cette eau en bouteille et qui
consomme malgré tout le peu d'eau
contaminé qui qui existe dans les
robinets quand ça veut bien
venir
voyez ça
réagit les résultats du contrôle
sanitaire on a pas d'inquiétude
spécifique à avoir sur nos résultats
d'analyse dans le sens où on est à plus
de 98 % de résultat conformes sur tout
confondu hein que je je parle de chimie
et de microbiologie donc il y a pas
d'inquiétude sur la qualité de l'eau du
robinet alors effectivement on a un
contexte particulier qui fait qu'on a
des problématiques des installations qui
sont vieillissantes et qui nécessitent
l'attention des opérateurs sur site au
quotidien
OK
[Musique]